ce confinement met donc à mal toute la
filière touristique et par ricochets le
secteur de l'hôtellerie si les hôtels
sont autorisées à rester ouverts la
clientèle se fait rare que ce soit à
l'auberge de jeunesse de tours ou dans
les chaînes d'hôtels qui accueille des
voyageurs d'affaires
le constat est partout le même
l'activité s'est effondrée sa malle
colin alors vous écoute ce serait pour
quelle date pour une seule nuit
ils font partie des rares à encore
prendre des réservations dans cet
établissement du centre de tours 5 à 10
chambres maximum sont occupés tous les
jours pour ce couple ça ne représente
même pas 10% de son chiffre mensuel
prévisionnel ils ont fait le choix de se
confiner sur place car un an après leur
ouverture et de confinement quelques
milliers d'euros gagnés c'est toujours
ça de pris
c'est une année de six mois c'est même
pas cessé c'est une année même de trois
mois de trois bons mois qui sont juillet
août et
en septembre on va dire les clients des
commerciaux des travailleurs du btp ou
toute autre personne avec des impératifs
médicaux par exemple une ou deux
chambres sont aussi occupés par des cas
contacts à l'isolément à une quinzaine
de kilomètres de là le château d'artigny
et sa grande salle de réception rideaux
fermés
donc là c'est un petit peu triste de
voir tout ce mobilier ranger même le
piano attend désespérément d'ordinaire
ici les clients viennent pour moitié de
l'étranger mais en ce moment le
restaurant le bar le spa et les 56
chambres sont vides évidemment l'hôtel
en profite pour réaliser des travaux de
rénovation sur les 45 salariés 3 reste
sur le site
quand on voit un petit peu les charges
les charges fixes
même si une grande partie du équipes
sont en chômage partiel
ce sont des pertes colossales chaque
semaine chaque mois
malgré les reports de charges est prêt
consenti par l'état
touraine hôtel s'attend à des
difficultés économiques dès le premier
trimestre 2001 21 et particulièrement
pour les indépendants en ce moment une
trentaine d'hôtels restent ouverts dans
le département